download this year all the actresses in
this category share a common experience
not only the anxiety the hope and the
pride inherent and having been nominated
for an Academy Award
what also the anxiety the pride and the
hope inherent and having been nominated
for the very first time the nominees for
the best actress in a supporting role
are Eileen Brennan in Private Benjamin
evila Galleon and resurrection Cathy
Moriarty in Raging Bull
anistar would and inside moons
and Mary Steenburgen and Melvin and
Howard
and the winner is Mary Steenburgen
you
well I'm going to have to figure out
something new to dream about that's for
sure nobody ever accused me being a fast
talker but I'm going to try tonight
because this supporting actress was
supported by a great many people a few
whom I would like to quickly thank I'd
like to thank my family in Arkansas for
always believing against all odds that
something like this is going to happen
and then I'd like to thank two teachers
sandy Meisner and Kenneth Gilliam for
the profound influence that they had
upon my work and then if anybody ever
had a patron saint it was me in 1977
when he insisted on casting me as his
leading lady in a film called going
south everybody told him he was crazy
but thank goodness for me that he was
and is Jack Nicholson thank you very
much
Thank You Melvin Dummar for the
inspiration bo goldman for the simple
splendor of your words and Jonathan Demi
thank you for your vision in your talent
and for the plain old-fashioned fun it
was to work with you thank you john
phillips Northlands and our producers
Jason Robards Paula Matt Pamela Reed and
the rest of the wonderful cast and crew
of Melvin and Howard and last of all I
must thank you Malcolm for making life
so nice that I feel like tap dancin
thanks a lot